family members of the nine Americans
killed in an ambush in Mexico are
disputing local authorities theory on
what happened victims relatives were
escorted to the place where their loved
ones died video shows an SUV riddled
with bullet holes and filled with toys
Manuel Bojorquez is in Ciudad Juarez
Mexico
Manuel what's next for the family a good
morning funerals will be held today for
Donna Langford and her two children as
well as ronita Miller and her four
children including eight month-old twins
and while his family grieves they are
also pressing for answers about what
prompted this attack Mexican government
officials now believe the killers who
opened fire on the families belonged to
La Linea part of the Cuates drug cartel
they shot down on it from the top they
say the attackers entered the territory
of the rival Sinaloa cartel Sunday near
La Mora where the extended LeBaron
family lived all members of a breakaway
group once associated with the Mormon
Church local police have been on high
alert ever since the two cartels engaged
in a gun battle early Monday morning
Mexican authorities believe the gunman
opened fire on the family's three SUVs
hours later first mistaking them for
cartel members and family members
including max LeBaron say the group was
targeted the question is then why target
this family these organizations usually
there's no reason there's no logical
reason behind that other than the fact
that they're just terrorist
organizations they point out that
children traveling with 29 year old
Christina Lankford Johnson say she
raised her arms to show she was not a
threat
she put her baby as far down as she
could in the vehicle she got out of the
vehicle she she asked him to she try to
identify that there was women and
children there and she got gunned down
Mexican officials say the first SUV was
hit by bullets and exploded around 9
a.m. Monday two hours later the other
two Suburbans were ambushed about 11
miles down the road after that shooting
a relative says 13 year-old Devon
Langford hid his siblings and bushes and
went for help about six hours later he
arrived in la mota 14 miles away and
alerted family members his uncle's were
forced to wait for army reinforcements
to arrive before they could set out to
find the children this is video of the
moment Christina Langford Johnston's
baby seven month-old faith was found
alive in the bullet-riddled SUV eleven
hours after the shooting in total eight
children were rescued three are still
recovering in an Arizona hospital the
Mexican president says he is open to the
u.s. working with local authorities in
this investigation officials here in
Mexico say more than 200 bullet casings
were found at the crime scene they say
those were manufactured by a us-based
gun maker and are commonly used in
military type assault rifles Gail many
the more details you hear the more
gut-wrenching it is thank you very much